on the biggest day of industrial
disruption in more than a decade a
national wave of strikes broke in
central London led by some of the
hundreds of thousands of teachers
demanding pay keep up with the cost of
living
if you feel you're fairly paid no no I
don't think anybody here does that's the
message then to the prime minister right
the message the prime minister is help
her help the kids help the teachers we
need some support I'm working very hard
and still the expenses the cost of
living has gone up and
[Applause]
public sector strikes have been going on
for months but this is the biggest show
of strength by far we've seen from a
union the turnout is huge it's very good
natured but they're very determined too
on a day the government says there's no
more money they're not about to give up
a demonstration of this size the fact
that the union is recruiting 40 000 new
members since we declared the strike
ballot
I hope what that will show the Secretary
of State and the government is that uh
they're not going to win this by
ignoring us
there was disruption across the UK
classrooms empty in Birmingham and
protests against anti-strike legislation
in the Welsh Capital University
lecturers walked out in Belfast a
driver's strike brought the railways to
a halt and one hundred thousand civil
servants closed more than 120 government
offices a collective challenge to a
government that says on pay it will not
negotiate
as a country We cannot put um you know
for some parts of society and inflation
or inflation plus rise which you know
many people are striking for what we
have to do is halve inflation that's the
most important thing or get it even
lower than that and then everybody in
the country will benefit we can't bake
in inflation which is what will happen
if we you know we start to get wages uh
spiraling out of control with unions in
bold and Deadlock promises more
disruption this turned out to be
repeated all over the country in rallies
in other towns cities and Villages it's
saying a clear message people are fed up
with the way they're being treated but
next week the health service will be out
on strike and there'll be rolling
strikes I'm confident right through the
spring and probably into the summer if
we don't get a deal the show's
solidarity may have deepened the
deadlock compromise seems a long way off
[Music]